did you when you because you just went
to egypt and we're going to talk about
the pyramids and the sphinx and all that
stuff
did you what did you find differently
about being in the middle east and doing
all that than this
um being here um i could do something
great like
the the pyramids and the sphinx i think
20 000 slaves well here's the thing yeah
uh the pyramids were the most unreal
things i've ever seen in my entire life
slavery built that right
i don't know if i believe that yeah you
think people willfully
picked up two ton stones and moved them
up there i think so
must have been a charismatic pharaoh
that [ __ ] told him that hey i think
was that pharaoh's name andrew schultz i
think okay so i think
we got to pick up the rocks akash right
[Laughter]
way
because we only hit him because we
[ __ ] truly love our gosh no that's
the thing the people you're like
gosh has the best sense of humor of
anyone he does i want him to hit me back
it'd be great because i will hit you
don't worry
yeah you got it coming you got it coming
boy yeah yeah
absolutely you're in the crosshairs of
flavor too i want to get hit by it
so um but what happens is
then i'm calling ice
you're like the jesse small out of
podcast you're trying to set it up for
the attention yeah you're like get me
flagrant dude get me i'm right over here
they came over they had a noose i want
to be canceled
yeah so so the pyramids they say were
built
4 000 years ago right which by the way
is wild
go back to what you said earlier which
is truth
is marketing sure whatever and there's
great marketing surrounding this [ __ ]
right there's books who built them did
jewish ladies build them
now that's baked into the religion it's
baked into the not only that religion
the religions that follow it
it's a lot of truth right as we say in
books right
what struck me as crazy the craziest
thing about the pyramids is this these
massive structures who can't even
understand how big they are until you're
there in front of them you cannot
understand it
i was speechless i'm not speechless
often and you're a tall drink of water
tall drink of water yeah
truly speechless yeah first thing that
hit me i go like this i'm saying
i'm staying in front of a great pair of
bees giza and i go
how much time uninterrupted would you
need to complete a project like this
uninterrupted yeah where the wars
you know you have this type of like
wealth you need wealth
and you need time in order to create
three of those in a row plus three
little ones and then they are practicing
other ones in the region wealth and time
how do you have that wealth in time so i
asked the guide
and they're like cairo's really
interesting city
the way it's located is on the right
side is an impenetrable forest
literally can't get in on the left is
the sahara
it's a desert you cannot exist in this
[ __ ] desert right
and then in the middle is the one river
in the whole world that flows north
and when it overflows in flood season
food grows out of the ground
at a rate that is uncomprehensible
so if human beings happen to stumble
upon
this little piece of land not only do
they have protection from all sides
they have a river flowing source with
clean water
food that on its own sprouts out of the
[ __ ] ground food is currency back in
the day we're talking about 4 000 years
ago maybe 10 000 years ago
yeah maybe thirty thousand years ago we
don't know really when every war used to
be fought over salt that's it
yeah that's it right well this is where
civilization started it's hard now yeah
right
and they defined civilization as writing
that's right and the egyptians were the
first to do that to do that that's what
they said
they got that well no no because it was
before mozzies muslims were only 1500
years old sandy's got that one sandy's
got down
so uh so so you have this situation
where
where they have the perfect opportunity
for prosperity
nobody [ __ ] for them and if you get a
benevolent dictator
in that time you could create some cool
[ __ ] now there's no [ __ ] tv there's
no instagram there's no movies there's
nothing they got some consolations that
they pretend look like orion yes that's
their cartoons they have literally
nothing to do yeah
you have food grown out everywhere you
need to organize society and you need to
have things
for people to do apparently and this
could be [ __ ] truth
but they have the community where the
workers lived and apparently they didn't
live poorly
they have like evidence of them eating
meat and drinking wine and beer
apparently they're doing like eight hour
shifts i don't know how they calculate
that kind of [ __ ]
but like and they said when i asked the
guy i was like i heard i thought that
jewish slaves built a pyramid
and she was like oh no that would never
happen and then he i was like why is
that she goes
you have to understand if this was a
religious temple you would never allow
someone to build it in honor of your god
that didn't believe in it
interesting she actually said something
interesting she said that that was a
marketing ploy
by jews because jews here we go again
this was interesting and this is what
she said she's like
jews believe that their promised land is
from the jordan river
to the nile which includes cairo
which includes giza is on the other side
of the river so you cross that river
into cairo
okay so that river where moses was found
is cairo
cairo right but the pyramids are in giza
the pyramids and giza on the other side
so just imagine manhattan
brooklyn there's also giza there's also
a [ __ ] pyramid in las vegas
so we got one too we got one too
makes a lot of money he does a lot of it
so it's just an interesting
interesting thing this these things
could be erected right and i don't
believe they're a tomb i don't believe
there any of that kind of [ __ ] i i don't
know what exactly they were but like
the way i th what happened my take away
from this experience with the pyramids
was this
i don't think that human progress is
linear
i used to think it was linear right i
used to think it's like humans cement
the wheel
sure we get some fire we get some
buildings we get some internet
and now here we are yeah i don't think
that i think that
humans given amazing circumstances like
cairo and probably mexico city and these
other
machu picchu and peru whatever can have
amazing
progression in short periods of time
sure but since we weren't global
societies back then
when a human group a civilization if you
will
went extinct their technology went
extinct with them they lost it all and
amazon tribe goes extinct right now they
probably have tons of remedies with the
leaves and the wood and that kind of
stuff
all that's gone yeah so i think this
society that built this was an advanced
human society maybe ten thousand maybe
twenty thousand made thirty thousand
years ago
there's water erosion markings on the
sphinx that are thirty thousand years
old apparently
right so i think they built that because
they lived in prosperity
they had amazing trajectory in terms of
you know technological advancement
and then they probably died out because
of famine or whatever it is
who knows what the [ __ ] was and then
afterwards our
humanity discover these pyramids and
then we start chipping away at them to
make stones this kind of [ __ ] like that
right
but the egyptians that made cairo did
not make the pyramids
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild
[Music]